So let's look at content cooking now and what does unreal handle for us by default?
So I've tried to include handy documentation links
You'll see the link at the bottom here about cooking content inside of unreal engine, but unreal engine
Is stored in particular file formats that are supported for any given platform
So, you know, we mentioned about our textures in the previous slide
And maybe you have some audio files or some skeletal mesh data or anything like this now
This is good for editing and developing purposes
But the target platforms will not want to read all these different formats. So what the cooking process does is
It converts them into a format that could be used for the the target platform
So, you know depending on the platform that you're wanting to deploy to you whether it's you know, a PC or a console or something
like that
There'll be different formats that the the platform wants and unreal engine handles that through the the process of cooking
now
again, these
Features are inside of our project settings. So again, just go to edit project settings if you want to find any of these
But as you saw at the start we're kind of cooking everything into our project and it didn't really allow us to select
You know specific maps, for example
maybe we have a bunch of you know prototype or sandbox my maps that we don't want to actually cook into our projects and we
just want to
Select a few things so a few different maps, so I'll just go through the process of how you might do this
So if if we just want again just a little bit more refined refinement
We only want to cook the maps for example and therefore any content within these specific maps
So it'll only find the maps with the content in your content browser. You can go to packaging
Advanced cook only maps again, you could search this term in the search box if you wanted to get them
but if you tick this option this will only affect the the maps that you've got in your
content browser, so
That's that's one way of doing it and you know, it's a tick box
But it helps refine our process a little bit
But if we really want to start getting a bit more specific about which maps we are
Cooking there is also a maps to cook section, which you know
I've just typed in the search box maps to cook so you'll be able to find this for yourself and
In this array at the bottom of the screen
You'll see the the property at the very bottom of this image list of maps to include in a package build
Instead of just having a bool which is that tick box at the top that says just get all the maps
This will actually give you a rate an array of very specific maps that you want to cook in your
package build which allows us say we have level 1 2 & 3 we can
Include level 1 2 & 3 into this array of maps to package and any other maps will be discarded
So if you had, you know again prototypes or sandboxes or anything like this that you didn't want to include in the package build
This is yet another way to
package certain maps
But if we want to get even more
Granular than this for example. So again, we're getting into a slight more detail slightly more detail. So
we do have other
settings and features inside of Unreal Engine that will allow you to really
Customize and get granular focus on some of these asset types. So in the left hand side, we have the asset manager and
Using the asset manager can give you control over which assets are loaded into your games content. So
You'll you really have a lot more fine control over that and I'll I'll share some links for this in the following slide
And then we also have the project launcher. It can be useful when packaging for multiple platforms
So you're trying to deploy again in the example that I used before or maybe a packaging for PC and packaging for console
you'll want to maybe use this project launcher just for
configurations per platform
So as I mentioned we have this asset manager and the link here is an excellent breakdown
If you're an engineer or want to know about what is being loaded into the game at any given point
I would highly recommend watching this video
It's a live stream from the Unreal Engine live stream and it really breaks down the asset manager in a granular way
So definitely worth watching
But as a high level the asset manager is a singleton global you object which is like an engine subsystem. So
This isn't map or most specific, you know, it's just one one manager to rule them all and it categorizes and queries
Unloaded assets using the asset registry, so it will just have this one
global asset load global asset loading state which is you know, what makes it a
Singleton like the engine subsystems, so you only ever have one that you can find it does integrate
Into existing systems like the cooking and async and it is designed to be overridden by your game. So
This is functionality already built into Unreal Engine that you can then extend and use for your own purposes
So if that sounds like something you need to do definitely check out the asset manager
Reference video there because that goes into all the different settings that you can have when extending this
Using the asset manager from an editor perspective is pretty straightforward
Again, we're in our project settings
And this time we're going to the game asset manager again, you could just type asset manager in the search bar if you want to
And you'll see here that we have a map type in the index
so in the array and index zero, we've got map type primary asset type map and
What this is actually looking for if you look down to the middle bottom of the image like the lower third of the image
You'll see directories here and in the index in the directories, you'll see that we're looking for game and then maps
so the really powerful thing about this is that we're looking into a specific folder of which maps to
Cook here. So
What why this is useful is say you have inside of your maps folder
You know
Critical levels or something like this you have a folder that's just called critical levels and you could add this to the directory and say anything
In this folder cook anything outside of this folder you don't cook and you could have these different folders again
This is an array so we could pick multiple different folder structures
But the powerful thing about this is I don't need to go in and when level 3 comes online
I don't have to go back into the previous maps to cook that we showed two slides ago
That says, okay now I need to add level 3 to cook now
I need to add level 4 and you know if you had 50 levels in your game
You could imagine, you know bugs might happen. You might miss a level something if you added each level individually
To the maps to cook. Yeah, you might run into issues that you can do it
But you know, it might be more time-consuming and error-prone
Whereas this approach just says any level inside this folder go ahead and cook
So that's that's another way of thinking about how you want to cook maps in this can be applied for different
Asset types, of course. I'm just using maps here as an example
but it shows you the power of you know from going from just
Opening the editor and clicking package my game for windows and taking the kitchen sink approach to get in more granular
Using the asset manager
So as we mentioned we also have the project launcher and this gives us the ability to deploy for different platforms
All in a centralized location from a single launch profile. So again, we've got the documentation link at the bottom left hand side here
So if you'd like to know more about the project launcher if you're working on games that are just for more than one platform
You'll probably want to start thinking about using the project launcher to make things a little bit easier to to manage
so the project launcher
Has its own default launch profile so you can see here I've got default launch profile for Windows and
I can choose to create custom profile that enables me to build a project in
That has many different advanced settings. So you can see that I've got a custom launch profile here called, you know
awesome profile, which is going to be the best possible settings for my
Projects here and you can configure different launch profiles again dependent on what you're wanting to use on the different platforms
so you can actually use this tool for
Testing DLC or patching and and just different organizational things
So, you know if you are running into you know, more of a commercial game project, it might be delivering on different
platforms you may have
Patches and DLC content things like this like that
The project launcher will definitely be a go-to and I think it's a note here
You'll see you know where I mentioned the Windows
Pete home here if I was on a network that had
You know development kits enabled and different PCs in my network
You'd be able to see all these different devices
listed here, so
You can set that up and the device manager as you can see the little clickable link there
But you can imagine the project launcher being really powerful again
If you're trying to ship your projects on multiple platforms here
Now when we're talking about the actual cook process
there
We we tend to just want to highlight these two different options. So we've got cook by the book and cook on the fly and
For 90% of you if not more you're probably going with cook by the book
However, if you're you know an engineer or wanting to iterate on quick changes
You might might want to cook on the fly. But let's just look about what this entails. So
We have cook by the book and cook by the book
Performs the entirety of the cook process ahead of time allowing for the build to deploy all the cooked assets at once
So this is what we did at the start of the tutorial here in the start of the course
We just cook by the book
We waited for everything to cook and package to turn into an executable and then that's what that's the content that we played
So this option is really useful for
Developers who are not wanting to iterate on individual assets and you're just trying to test your game
So this this is generally for performance testing and play tests things like this
so that would be the default probably for a lot of you, however, we do have the cook on the fly option and
It will delay cooking until after the game has been deployed
So I'm gonna break down the different stages of actually packaging and what this goes through in a few slides here
But you actually delay the cooking process until after the game has been deployed
Which means I can just deploy the game very quickly
but also
Uses the network communication with a cook server to make requests on demand and then the content is cooked on
As as and when it's needed so this is for fast iteration
So if things have already been cooked and you just want to deploy, you know
You can deploy the build relatively quickly and then it'll only be cooking content as and when it gets to
The content that needs cooking so, you know, if you're trying to bug test or really find this one thing
You don't want to wait for a full build to be deployed cook on the fly might be an option for you there